in this video we're going to talk about
the stratosphere the second layer in the
atmosphere stretching from about ten
kilometers now to you to about 50
kilometers an altitude now if you didn't
see the previous episode where we
introduced the atmosphere and it's
layers or if you just like a refresher
then click the link you might recall
from last time that the stratosphere
differed from the troposphere because of
its temperature profile how the
temperature changed with height in the
troposphere temperatures decrease with
altitude whereas in the stratosphere
temperatures increased without statute
and this property gives it some very
unusual dynamics that we don't see here
at the surface to explore this and to
make things a little more rigorous we
use a concept called
air parcels first of all let's isolate a
little chunk of air in the atmosphere
and we can imagine doing this by using a
transparent balloon with a few special
properties you envelop a section of air
and tie it off and the material that has
made up the balloon doesn't allow heat
to transfer from one side to the other
so the air inside the balloon is
thermally isolated from its surroundings
and the balloon also doesn't weigh
anything so it's kind of an imaginary
construct and what we've created then
that chunk of air is referred to as an
air parcel and playing with this air
parcel allows us to understand a little
more deeply how the different layers in
the atmosphere differ let's say that our
air parcel is minding its own business
and then all of a sudden it gets
vertically displaced this could be by
flowing over a mountain and being pushed
up it could be pushed out of the way by
an aircraft wing or could just be pushed
by a careless PhD student now what
happens next depends on where you are in
the atmosphere now let's say we're in
the troposphere and we take our air
parcel and move it vertically upwards
doing so we've created a chunk of air
which is warmer than its surroundings
and it's warmer than its surroundings
because air gets cooler the higher you
go in the troposphere and our air parcel
is thermally isolated from its
surroundings so we take a lump of air
that's slightly warmer and moved it into
a place where the air is slightly cooler
however the air parcel is at the same
pressure as its surroundings and the
pressure at a level in the atmosphere
comes from the weight of all of the air
above that point in the atmosphere now
we can use the temperature and
of a gas to work out its density which
is its mass divided by its volume or in
other words how much mass one cubic
meter of that gas would have and we can
do this using what's called the ideal
gas equation we can rearrange this
equation so that we work out the density
which we typically represent by the
Greek letter Rho and we find that an air
parcel which is at the same pressure as
its surroundings but is warmer has a
higher temperature we find that it is
less dense and so like a bubble of air
with low density surrounded by water
with high density our parcel of air
rises and it keeps rising and keeps
rising until something else gets in the
way this is called instability and it
governs a lot of how the troposphere
works in the troposphere air is able to
move vertically and transport heat and
water vapor freely like in clouds for
example now let's see what would happen
if we repeat that experiment but in the
stratosphere instead of the troposphere
we take our air parcel shift it
vertically upwards and watch as it sinks
gently back down to its original
position let's go back to the ideal gas
equation because the temperature in the
stratosphere increases with altitude we
see the are displaced air parcel which
is at the same pressure as its
surroundings is cooler than its
surroundings and so has a higher density
this means then that is the opposite of
what happens in this troposphere and
sinks this phenomenon is called static
stability and it's what makes the
stratosphere so different from a
troposphere
there's no large-scale vertical movement
of air masses in the stratosphere
in fact the name stratosphere comes from
the fact that it is stratified lots of
different layers of air on top of one
another that don't communicate with each
other all of that much it's for this
reason that commercial airliners
typically fly in the lower stratosphere
they're literally flying above the
storms of the troposphere as well as
getting a boost from the strong winds
and the blast dense air because of all
of this the stratosphere is regarded as
generally being quite quiescent and well
boring and this may be true a lot of the
time but sometimes the stratosphere
turns nasty
the most violent events in the whole
atmosphere take place in it and we're
going to talk about them in a future
video so you'll have to stick around to
find out what I mean with any kind of
science there has to be the question of
application
how does understanding this stuff impact
and improve our daily lives and the
answer this question is kind of still
being written for the longest time if
people just thought that the
stratosphere was this quiescent layer
above our party atmosphere that we
influenced but it didn't influence us
but some recent work notably some by my
supervisor has shown that this isn't
really the case the stratosphere isn't
just a lid to the troposphere it impacts
surface weather in quite a big way and
so by improving our understanding of the
stratosphere we can hopefully improve
our surface weather forecasts which
pretty much everyone on earth agrees is
a good thing to do and it's particularly
exciting because the stratosphere is a
relatively predictable part of the
Earth's atmosphere with a few notable
exceptions we can predict relatively far
into the future what the stratosphere
will be doing and so if we can take
generated stratospheric data and apply
it to surface weather forecasts we can
predict further into the future and more
accurately than we currently can with an
improved understanding of the
stratosphere but that's the theory at
least part of my PhD is actually trying
to work out how we're supposed to do
this and I'm quite a way off an answer
just yet before we go this time I want
to introduce you to one new piece of
physics and it's something that we're
gonna be referring back to you time and
time again in this video series starting
with the next video that piece of
physics is the first law of
thermodynamics
it sounds very scary but it's actually
very simple and it has to do with energy
energy can be defined as the ability to
do work and it comes in many different
forms an object which is moving very
fast has a lot of kinetic energy which
enables it to do a lot of work for
example against gravity
if you shoot something vertically
upwards with a lot of kinetic energy in
other words shoot it very quickly then
it will go very high whereas if you
shoot something vertically we're not
quite so much velocity meaning it has
not quite so much kinetic energy
won't reach so high that object wasn't
able to do as much work against gravity
or equivalently the object had less
kinetic energy to convert into
gravitational potential energy the
higher an object is the more
gravitational potential energy it has
and so to get higher you must have more
energy to convert into gravitational
potential energy this is the fundamental
idea of the first law of thermodynamics
energy cannot be created or destroyed
only transfer from one form into another
what thermodynamics specifically talks
about is heat which is thermal energy
moving from one object to another a hot
object has a lot of thermal energy while
a cooler object has bless and if the
amount of thermal energy in an object is
increasing then its temperature must
also increase and this happens when the
amount of energy flowing into an object
is greater than the amount of energy
flowing out of it now that energy
imbalance can't just go missing it has
to be converted into another form of
energy and in this case that form of
energy is thermal energy equally if the
amount of energy flowing out of an
object is greater than the amount of
energy flowing into it then its
temperature must decrease the energy
imbalance in the flow in and out has to
be converted into a change in another
form of energy and that change of form
of energy is a decrease in thermal
energy remember this concept for next
time as will be making extensive use of
it so in this video we've covered how
the troposphere is dynamically unstable
while the stratosphere is statically
stable we've compared and contrasted how
different the dynamics are in the
stratosphere and the troposphere we've
answered the question of why we're
interested in studying the stratosphere
to improve our surface weather forecasts
and also introduce the first law of
thermodynamics that energy can't be
created or destroyed only transferred
from one form into another in the next
video we're going to delve deeper into
the stratosphere and try and answer the
question of why it has that peculiar
property of being hotter the higher you
go we're also going to introduce some
new concepts in atmospheric physics and
answer the question of why a zone and
the ozone layer is so important to all
of this thank you for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please
do give it a like and consider
subscribing to this channel for more
educational content by remitting
slightly less radiation than it absorbs
a layer in the atmosphere warm slightly
due to the first law of thermodynamics
and basically reading in detail and
writing them up in scientific language
called leh Tech it's a scientific
typesetting languages make up to meet
with Julie